[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chapter six
coraline was woken by the mid-morning
sun full on her face
for a moment she felt utterly dislocated
she did not know where she was she was
not entirely sure who she was
it is astonishing just how much of what
we are can be tied to the beds we wake
up in the morning
and it is astonishing how fragile that
can be sometimes coraline would forget
who she was while she was daydreaming
that she was exploring the arctic or the
amazon rainforest or darkest africa
and it was not until someone tapped her
on the shoulder or said her name that
coraline would come back from a million
miles away with a start
and all in a fraction of a second have
to remember
who she was and what her name was and
that she was even there at all
now there was the sun on her face and
she was coraline jones
yes and then the green and pinkness of
the room she was in and the rustling of
the large painted paper butterfly as it
fluttered and beat its way about the
ceiling
told her where she had woken up she
climbed out of the bed
she could not wear her pajamas dressing
gown and slippers during the day she
decided
even if it meant wearing the other
coraline's clothes
was there an other car line no she
realized there wasn't there was just her
there were no regular clothes in the
cupboard though they were more like
dressing up clothes or
she thought the kind of clothes she
would love to have hanging in her own
wardrobe at home
there was a raggedy witch costume a
patched scarecrow costume a future
warrior costume with little digital
lights in it that glittered and blinked
a slinky evening dress all covered in
feathers and mirrors
finally in a drawer she found a pair of
black jeans that seemed to be made of
velvet night
and a gray sweater the color of thick
smoke with faint and tiny stars in the
fabric which twinkled
she pulled on the jeans and the sweater
then she put on a pair of bright orange
boots she found at the bottom of the
cupboard
she took her last apple from the pocket
of her dressing gown and then took
from the same pocket the stone with the
hole in it
she put the stone into the pocket of her
jeans and it was as if her head had
cleared a little
as if she had come out of some sort of
fog
she went into the kitchen but it was
deserted still she was sure there was
someone in the flat
she walked down the hall until she
reached her father's study and
discovered
that it was occupied where's the other
mother
she asked the other father he was
sitting in the study at a desk which
looked just like her father's but he was
not doing anything at all
not even reading gardening catalogs as
her own father did when he was only
pretending to be working
out he told her fixing the doors there
are some vermin problems
he seemed pleased to have somebody to
talk to the rats you mean
no the rats are our friends this is the
other kind big black fellow with its
tail high
the cat you mean that's the one
said her other father he looked less
like her true father tick day
there was something slightly vague about
his face like bread dough that had begun
to rise
meeting up the bumps and cracks and
depressions
really i mustn't talk to you when she's
not here he said
but don't you worry she won't be gone
often i shall demonstrate our tender
hospitality to you such that you will
not even think about ever going back
he closed his mouth and folded his hands
in his lap
so what am i to do now ask coraline the
other father pointed to his lips
silence if you won't even talk to me sin
coraline i'm going exploring no point
said the other father there isn't
anywhere but here
this is all she made the house the
grounds and the people in the house
she made it and she waited then he
looked embarrassed and he put one finger
to his lips again as if he had just said
too much
coraline walked out of his study she
went into the drying room over to the
old door
and she pulled it rattled and shook it
no
it was locked fast and the other mother
had the key
she looked around the room it was so
familiar that was what made it feel so
truly strange
everything was exactly the same as she
remembered it was all her grandmother's
strange smelling furniture there was the
painting of the bowl of fruit
a bunch of grapes two plums a peach and
an apple hanging on the wall
there was the low wooden table with the
lion's feet and the empty fireplace
which seemed to suck heat from the room
but there was something else something
she did not remember seeing before
a ball of glass up on the mantelpiece
she went over to the fireplace went up
on tiptoes and lifted it down
it was a snow globe with two little
people in it coraline shook it and said
the snow flying
white snow that glittered as it tumbled
through the water then she put the snow
globe back on the mantelpiece and
carried on looking for her true parents
and for way out she went out of the flat
past the flashing light store behind
which the other mrs [ __ ] and forcible
performed their show forever
and she set off into the woods where
coraline came from
once you were through the patch of trees
you saw nothing but the meadow and the
old tennis court
in this place the woods went on further
the trees became cruder and less
tree-like the further you went
pretty soon they seemed very approximate
like the idea of trees a grayish-brown
truck below a green splotch of something
that might have been leaves above
coraline wondered if the other mother
wasn't interested in trees
or if she just hadn't bothered with this
bit properly because nobody was expected
to come out this far
she kept walking and then the mist began
it was not damp like a normal fog or
mist it was not cold and it was not warm
it felt decor line like she was walking
into nothing
i'm an explorer thought coraline to
herself and i need all the ways out of
here that i can get
so i shall keep walking the world she
was walking through was a pale
nothingness
like a blank sheet of paper or an
enormous empty white room
it had no temperature no smell no
texture and no taste
it certainly isn't missed that coraline
although she did not know what it was
for a moment she wondered if she might
not have gone blind but no
she could see herself plain as day but
there was no ground beneath her feet
just a misty milky whiteness
and what do you think you're doing set a
shape to one side of her
it took a few moments for her eyes to
focus on it properly
she thought it might be some kind of
line at first some distance away from
her
and then she thought it might be a mouse
close beside her
and then she knew what it was i'm
exploring
coraline told the cat its first stood
straight out from its body and its eyes
were wide while its tail was down in
between its legs
it did not look like a happy cat bad
place said the cat
if you want to call it a place which i
don't what are you doing here
and exploring nothing to find here said
the cat this is just the outside
the part of the place she hasn't
bothered to create
she the one who says she's your other
mother said the cat
what is she asked coraline the cat did
not answer just patted through the pale
mist beside coraline
a sheep began to appear in front of them
something high and towering and dark
you were wrong she told the cat there is
something there
and then it took shape in the midst a
dark house which loomed at them
out of the formless whiteness but that's
said coraline
the house you just left or greet the cat
precisely
maybe i just got turned around at the
mist said coraline
the cat curled the high tip of its tail
into a question mark and tipped its head
to one side
you might have done it said i certainly
not wrong indeed but how can you walk
away from something and still come back
to it
easy said the cat think of somebody
walking around the world you start out
walking away from something and end up
coming back to it
small world said coraline it's big
enough for her said the cat
spider's webs only have to be large
enough to catch flies
coraline shivered he said that she's
fixing all the gates and the doors
she told the cat to keep you out she may
try said the cat
unimpressed oh yes she may try they were
standing under another clump of trees
now
beside the house these trees looked much
more likely
there's ways in and ways out of places
like this that even she doesn't know
about
did she make this place then ask
coraline
made it found it what's the difference
ask the cat either way
she's had it a very long time hang on
and it gave a shiver and a leap and
before coraline could blink the cat was
sitting with its paw holding down a big
black rat it's not that i like rats at
the best of times
said the cat conversationally as if
nothing had happened
but the rats in this place are all spies
for her
she uses them as her eyes and hands and
with that the cat let the rat go
it ran several feet and then the cat
with one bound was upon it
batting it hard with one sharp clawed
paw
well with the other paw it held the rat
down i love this bit
said the cat happily want to see me do
that again
no said coraline why do you do it you're
torturing it
hmm said the cat it let the rat go
the rat stumbled dazed for a few steps
then it began to run
with the blow of its paw the cat knocked
the rat into the air and caught it in
its mouth
stop it said coraline the cat dropped
the wrap between its two front paws
there are those it's said with the sigh
and tones as
smooth as oiled silk who have suggested
that the tendency of cat to play with
its prey is a merciful one
after all it permits the occasional
funny little running snack to escape
from time to time
how often does your dinner get to do
that and then it picked the rat up in
its mouth and carried it off into the
woods behind a tree
coraline walked back into the house all
was quiet and empty and deserted
even her footsteps on the carpet seemed
loud dust boats hung in a beam of
sunlight
at the end of the hall was the mirror
she could see herself walking toward the
mirror looking
reflected a little braver than she
actually felt
there was nothing else there in the
mirror just her in the corridor
a hand touched her shoulder and she
looked up the other mother stared down
at core line with big black button eyes
coraline my darling she said i thought
we could play some games together this
morning now you're back from your walk
hopscotch happy families monopoly
you weren't in the mirror said coraline
the other mother smiled
mirrors she said are never to be trusted
now what game shall we play coraline
shook her head
i don't want to play with you she said i
want to go home and be with my real
parents i want you to let them go to let
us all go
the other mother shook her head very
slowly sharper than a servant's tooth
she said is a daughter's ingratitude
still the proudest spirit can be broken
with love and her long white fingers
waggled and caressed the air
i have no plans to love you said
coraline no matter what you can't make
me love you
let's talk about it said the other
mother and she turned and walked into
the lounge
coraline followed her the other mother
sat down on the big sofa she picked up a
shopping bag from beside the sofa and
took out a white wrestling paper bag
from inside it
she extended the hand with it to
coraline would you like one
she asked politely expecting it to be a
toffee or a butterscotch ball coraline
looked down
the bag was filled with large shiny
black beetles
crawling over each other in their
efforts to get out of the bag
no said coraline i don't want one suit
yourself
said her other mother she carefully
picked out a particularly large and
black beetle pulled off its legs which
she dropped neatly into a blanket glass
ashtray on the small table besides sofa
and popped the beetle into her mouth
she crunched it happily young she said
and took another you're sick said
carline
sick and evil and weird is that any way
to talk to your mother
her other mother asked with her mouth
full of black beetles
you aren't my mother said coraline her
other mother ignored this
now i think you're a little over excited
coraline perhaps this afternoon we could
do a little embroidery together or some
watercolor painting
then dinner and then if you have been
good you may play with the rats a little
before bed
and i shall read you a story and tuck
you in and kiss you good night
her long white fingers fluttered gently
like tired butterfly
and coraline shivered no said coraline
the other mother sat on the sofa her
mouth was set in a line
her lips were pursed she popped another
black beetle into her mouth and then
another
like someone with a bag of chocolate
covered raisins her big black button
eyes stared into coraline's hazel eyes
her shiny black hair twined and twisted
about her neck and shoulders
as if it were blowing in some wind that
coraline could not touch or feel
they stared at each other for over a
minute then the other mother said
manners
she folded the white paper bag carefully
so no black beetles could escape
and she placed it in the shopping bag
then she stood up
and up and up she seemed taller than
coraline remembered
she reached into her apron pocket and
pulled out first the black door key
which she frowned at and tossed into her
shopping bag
then a tiny silver colored key she held
it up triumphantly
there we are she said this is for you
coraline
for your own good because i love you
to teach you manners manners maketh man
after all
she pulled coraline back into the
hallway and advanced upon the mirror at
the end of the hall
then she pushed the tiny key into the
fabric of the mirror
and she twisted it it opened like a door
revealing a dark space behind it you may
come out
when you've learned some manners said
the other mother
and when you're ready to be a loving
daughter she picked coraline up
and pushed her into the dim space behind
the mirror
a fragment of beetle was sticking to her
lower lip and there was no
expression at all in her black button
eyes
then she swung the mirror door closed
and left coraline
in darkness
[Music]